de tout mon excuse moi à s'excuser
johnson sur ce terme hall 2 types pour
la rentrée on rappelle la narration pour
la lacc
mika nous avait mis la mine on va tout
savoir cinq vit chacun pour sa gueule le
nom de chacun s'affiche à l'écran le
gisti les jaunes tuer le bleu et il est
le blanc voilà généré en fait on est mal
n hockey est le but c'est de personnes
bon allons surtout le but c'est de
percer le coeur des autres changements
voilà comment on utilise la gâchette
pour ça un peu temps volé on s'en
souvient forcément quoi mais si je te
rends compte que je vais t'arracher
terrain guardian est éliminé de comme
d'habitude
tieger voilà aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
pas grave elle est comme ça je ça me
permet de bien de tuer et à nous c'est
bientôt la fin pour toi à bientôt
il faudrait qu'on trouve un jeu alex
haut que moi je puisse m'amuser en
attendant d'être ralentie en fait c'est
une astuce mal j'ai toute une ville mais
après il va encore tout gagner ça va ça
va chien c'est vraiment énervant requis
comme soit à la fois super prenait
encore joue des bananes des baleines pas
mal oui toujours troisièmes mika yann
par donc fidèle au poste et comme on dit
je le peux que progresser ne peut que
vous avez céderait sombrer davantage
vraiment j'adore j'ai quand même
jusqu'au bout des temps et un homme est
en fait un vin blanc ou yann au possible
et je vais te manger je vais très bien
prononcé quand on les paie soit jeté
l'épongé
j'en ai marre j'ai gagné c'est le geste
fait de dire c'est la compétence à la
bombe j'en ai gagné deux tu es bon ça
c'est un battant il ya trop de jeunes
ont à la fois la regarde tout de suite
lille son staff ou bien la ja nous si tu
dois passer lagardère c'est lagardère
qui cette fois est effectivement voilà
je suis enfui
non l'amour lui 4 j'ai jeté ton pull
marvel pourtant tout sur mika juge par
l'anti juste là juste là on est vraiment
allé dit si je suis planté d'un sushi
j'en ai marre de faire le voyage
oui j'y suis mais non c'est tt sur moi
en tout cas moi ça je m'en fous
royalement ben moi je m'en fous beaucoup
moins qu'en fait c'est les angles droits
qui nous qu'à contrecoeur
comme il l'a fait la batterie taille âge
et j'ai jamais pas d agir ici ça c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est magnifique
à caen sloppy trompe pas quand c'est
trop c'est pure piqueront vient à mika
vient bien sûr ça me fait ça pique nique
de gala des oui il fait rire mais je
pense que françois fillon se référencent
le fait pour un peu moins est ce que tu
feras un compte de bach nombre de fois
où mickey a dit mon petit coeur mais en
fait je pense qu'ils adressent un
message à une abonnée peut-être mais si
toi tu pensais être le petit choeur de
mika une finale qui n'est du jamais vu
est-ce que j'ai marié un tout droit dans
le cas
non vraiment très beau travail d'équipé
vraiment bravo
francis lalanne
abbassian a fait qu'il ya une note aussi
qu' et tout d'un coup du squeeze
j'arrête tout de suite non non moi je
m'enfuis dans ce petit trou ah ouais bah
je te rejoins ce petit et tu n'aurais
peut-être pas dû mon ami implenia nous
éloigner ses membres en jeu le poignet
comme saint-louis n'y ait choisi le pas
tout et owen jouera jeu habitat c'est
clair on est tous contre mika a compris
tout cas le sens bien je me sens bien
c'est pas grave y'a de la vengeance est
toujours possible voilà allez mon
console ya nous s'il vous plaît
messieurs dames je sais pas comment mais
mais on compte là la beauté
il quitte la pièce sans d'abandon vadis
et moi je me le fais vite fait pour toi
une nouvelle offre
il a perdu bien où tu te rends ianu
qu'est ce qui t'as aimé attaque j'ai
gagné voici le briane genève as tu t'es
content ouais c'est sûr je suis génial
ouais c'est ça se voyait pas bon quand
on arrive par derrière comme ça et tu
fais pas qui la lie à nous je vois que
je te donne moi ton coeur béton cordes m
et déjà déjà punition ensuite munitions
le conquet montre coeur et coeur
mais qui alors le maître select chez un
ami booba ou pomme n'est pas sorti de
chez moi s'il vous plaît allez tu es toi
aussi
non mais tu y vas vraiment êtes vous
prêt pour une manche suivante messieurs
dames comme ça ça ne va pas du tout à
quoi les médias passent mais les
manchettes futari faut saluer comme ça
on n'a qu'à faire c'est même là c'est
toi qui nous attend mais est morte c'est
bon on avait mal à y aller alors oui
elle était bien quoi maintenant que vous
ne savez pas où on met une vie une vie
les amis moi je parle aussi longtemps
que vous aviez un truc de la talonne
avec mon projet plus mont blanc sas et
dire que vous avez fait un truc
différent mais pas mon art est de la
belgique au but j'ai compris c'est du
deux contre un pour simplement aller moi
je me
on affronte le monde de mickey
attention il ya la lavande les amis
et voilà il faut se rappeler contrôles
sont quand même assez spatiale est passé
à la toile et à thouars aléatoire allez
me sucer moi d'avoir bientôt à l'essai
j'allais ce qu'ils voient là un joli
attend aussi ta merde moi je regarde en
arrière en équipe
en 2004 c'est comment ça finit
et à tuer d'entrée du bateau mais j'ai
un peu peur mais je suis mort à
contrecoeur c'est là tu es note donc lé
blog carré des vagues à temps
oui mais voilà et hop là on appelle aux
pouvoirs qui me sont conférés je raconte
ça c'est sûr si j'allais dire non mais
c'est super bien les gones mais gadret
ouah ça va être super journée
on y racontera j'attends depuis 22
minutes pour jouer environ et ben voila
voila le dire merci beaucoup monsieur
attention dernière partie celui qui
gagne c'est la gagne tout voilà ce que
ça arrange souvent ce type est un très
bon comme ça surtout comme toi aussi
mais lloris mais il ya un an mika c'est
juste toi que ça arrange pas tiens juste
derrière suis mal ses fins moi même si
je perds tu sais quoi tu mois pour moi
c'est une image encore m
cherchez la bombe l'agencé de la faune
102e petite ville en compagnie de
michaël youn à la maison mika ça sert à
rien d'essayer de tuer comme un viol h
on remercie aussi kiki kiwi meilleur ami
de yann merci à l'abonné qui me l'a
donné à paris games week en fait c'était
un cadeau d'une abonnés n'hésitez pas à
le voir son twitter et youtube sera
description et puis on se retrouve très
vite dans une nouvelle vidéo sur tout le
monde à un piece by piece